oh here we are back at it again holy
[ __ ]
oh my god I'm not barrels I hate this up
should we knock yeah hello the [ __ ] is
this hey they got corn and everything
unload I miss the man man you look good
man good oh Jesus crisis get the [ __ ]
out of me why is there tricycle here oh
god it's getting dark man it's getting
well dark man oh [ __ ]
you know shits about to go down when the
drum starts hitting it
oh god this is [ __ ] creepy man what
was that
[Music]
all right but this is pretty good so far
what a nice town oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ]
indeed oh that's cool man this is so
[ __ ] cool
[Music]
whoa what the [ __ ] Hey no I hear you
Ethan Bradberry what the [ __ ] are you
doing you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why you gotta be so loud man I ain't
scared
Oh Geoff Lada Fichte oh corn I love corn
so much Oh
time over oh thank god [ __ ] I am so [ __ ]
[ __ ] this oh my god
I'm fine fine I'm fine I'm fine
where where am I it excuse me
I broke when I'm excited miter doesn't
appreciate it I know but whoa it's licky
tongue again that [ __ ] Pokemon scat
mates yeah what the [ __ ] are those
what the [ __ ] is a oh okay no that's
great that's funny cuz I was actually
heading this way towards the exit yes
oh come on all right come out puts out a
shudder ran out of batteries downhill
and things like a bad what was that what
the [ __ ] is out there oh god this is
[ __ ] creepy man
oh Sh okay okay oh Jesus Christ
get the [ __ ]
[Music]